[Music]
what is up everybody it's an iMac here
for anime uproar and Netflix actually
just released an official teaser trailer
for their live action death note
adaptation which will be an original
netflix movie that will come out on
august twenty fifth of this year now
this teaser is less than a minute long
however it does show us some interesting
things so i thought i'd talk about it
really quickly right now as always here
at a time after we want to be your go-to
place for all the latest anime news and
theories so if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you can be the
first to know and now getting into the
teaser our hero is light turner this guy
right here with the blond highlights all
the emo all of it so after we see email
light getting the death note for the
first time we are showing a clip of high
school cheerleaders which right away to
me is a red flag that this is going to
be a very Americanized version of the
story if you look at the cheerleader in
the middle she's smoking a cigarette
she's very badass and that is actually
supposed to be the Misa Amane of this
story however her name is MIA Sutton
then we see what could be assist Lord or
something along those lines however this
is actually the L of this adaptation
played by American rapper and actor
Keith Stanfield so we have not wolf as
light Turner Margaret kweli as Mia
Sutton and Keith Stanfield as L Paul not
Kochi as what that he appears to be the
only Japanese American in a significant
role in this whole adaptation and then
we also have Willem Dafoe as the voice
of Ryu now I don't really want to get
into the whole race and casting topic
since i'm sure everyone else will get
into the topic for me however i will say
that i think that either light or l
should have been played by a Japanese
American or Japanese actor as a tribute
to the original work I think that L
especially as an international detective
could have been played by a Japanese
actor and after the Japanese 2006
adaptation where he was portrayed so
spot-on I don't really know how you top
that I mean that is amazing look at that
hair I wish I wish I could give my hair
like that
one day we do get a quick preview of
willem dafoe as the voice of rio and i
will say that he sounds really good
that's definitely a positive just take a
listen shall we begin
[Music]
and we don't get too much more
information in this very quick teaser
and I don't want to be too quick and
judging this adaptation however when I
see the cheerleaders when I see the
blond highlights these are definitely
red flags to me that this could be a
very Americanized version of the story
that could definitely straight way too
far from the original and with that I
have to say that my expectations for
this are not high at all but I am
interested in hearing your opinion so be
sure to let me know what you think down
in the comments and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell for all the
latest anime news and updates and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]